good morning John today I would like to
talk to you and no H yes today's video
is going to be about the fact the
universe does not have an edge and we're
going to start with the observable
universe we often use universe
interchangeably with observable universe
which is the universe that we can
conceivably see given that photons have
to travel from the edge of it to us
before we can see the observable
universe is a sphere and it centers upon
the observer anything that each and
every one of us looking out at the night
sky we are the center of the observable
universe the observable universe is like
the observable ocean if you're sitting
on the beach there's a horizon out there
but of course what this doesn't mean is
that there isn't more stuff out there
beyond what we see as the edge of the
universe no edge the universe can also
be defined as just everything there is
and of course it's impossible to say
that there is something outside of
everything no that one was creepy but
that's not actually a very good
definition of the University what the
universe really is is this evenly dense
ever expanding mass of stuff that we can
study and we have learned many
fascinating things about a lot of people
say to me Hank the universe is expanding
it has to be cleaning into something and
expanding into something there has to be
an edge there's nothing here and there's
universe here right cuz it's expanding
no it's actually not expanding into
something it's just expanding I'm gonna
try to explain that the Big Bang was not
an explosion the way that we think about
explosions when things shooting off and
you know more stuff in the middle then
as it expands out there's less stuff the
Big Bang was not like that and the
universe is not like that just like
there is no edge there is no Center
after that cosmological moment of the
Big Bang everything existed and was
evenly spaced and remains that way
though gravity likes makes little clumps
but overall the universe is evenly dense
when we say that the universe is
expanding we don't mean that individual
galaxies and planets are shooting out
away from one another what we mean is
that the fabric that they exist in is
stretching in order to freak you out
just a tiny bit more if you wanted to
find the physical geographical place
where the Big Bang started it would be
everywhere we're not actually sure
whether the universe is infinite current
data suggests that it is
it's perfectly possible that the
universe is infinite and also expanding
which no age I know I'm right there with
you dude so yes it may just be that some
infinities are larger than other
infinities the universe also on the
other hand might be finite somewhere out
beyond where we can see there might be
on edge wait are you gonna be okay
edge yeah I know maybe probably maybe I
better love us beyond what we can see
there is certainly more and if there is
an edge we will never see it and we will
never know it there are also a lot of
other reasons why this is fascinating
I'm not going to get into all of those
reasons maybe I will write a blog post
about it by the way speaking of blog
posts my tumblr died it's complicated
but if you were following me on tumblr
you don't have to go follow me on tumblr
again I'm sorry please do that cuz I'll
miss you otherwise also there's a very
limited quantity of these still existing
if you would like to get one it's the
Tour de nerd fighting CD which I had at
the Tour de nerd fighting but we had
extras and I don't want to throw them
away John even though it seems that you
don't think the universe is
appropriately interesting I still like
you a lot and I will see you on Tuesday
no edge hello endscreen if you are
wondering basically this video is what
scishow is all the time except scishow
has nicer production value so you may
want to go to youtube.com slash scishow
and subscribe
[Music]